[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with an effort to
preserve and celebrate black history
for decades saint emma was the nation's
only military academy dedicated
exclusively to educating young black men
thousands graduated in its 70-plus year
existence while much of the school is
gone the lessons instilled in its
graduates run deep and that's what's
fueling the drive to have history
acknowledge this exceptional school
deborah alfarone reports
down a gated road
past a forgotten cemetery
in a small virginia community called
powhatan
sits a little known trace of
african-american history even the power
town historical society they don't have
any history of seeing them
but saint emma military academy existed
along with its sister school for young
women saint francis de sales from 1895
until 1972
thousands of young african-american men
and women attended school here including
bob walker and eugene butler and that's
me there i am right there
why do you think people don't know so
much about this place people didn't want
uh
this school in this community
you know a lot of prejudice and racism
was going on the site was built at a
time when racial segregation forbade
african-american children from attending
schools with white children
the education of african americans at
that time okay at a time that things
were very very difficult a bunch of
young men and a bunch of young ladies
from saint francis they're getting
groomed to be better room to work in
society
walker class of 65 and butler class of
68 say the rigorous training and
education they received in this secluded
setting shaped their character forever
discipline
a structured lifestyle
humility
trust
[Music]
walker went on to join the marines and
butler became a positions assistant
they largely credit this man the
commandant of the academy father figaro
was shaping them into who they are today
if things weren't going your way he
would say tough
deal with it yeah and move on
because we're not here to stand still
but it wasn't all work and no play the
two friends showed me pictures from when
they would attend socials with the young
ladies of saint francis
if you got too close they would come in
between you and pick you up
we have this much distance between you
dancing it wasn't until years later they
learned what this land once was we
didn't notice the plantation we came
here i came from new york i'm back in
these woods that's all i knew yeah and i
didn't know it was a plantation until we
graduated
a cemetery on the same land as their
former classrooms is a final resting
place for 130 enslaved people who built
the institution that gave them so much
we're standing on the shoulders of those
people this was an area of enslavement
that turned to empowerment
behind us is a beautiful gothic revival
mansion
that was built by a confederate general
basically in the 1840s
the schools have been closed for 50
years walker and butler are teaming up
with the land's new owner and historian
john plaschle to keep the story of saint
emma and saint francis or what's left of
it alive
when i came back up here years ago and i
saw there was nothing here
it was devastating to me
because i was wondering why would they
take these buildings and implode these
buildings and leave the big house
which was the plantation
mansion
and that was it
and the chapel and st peter claver
morale hall the agricultural buildings
the gymnasium what they had just built
in 1972 i believe
and and just all gone plashell started
leading tours of the academy nearly two
years ago in an effort to raise funds
for a commemorative marker or museum and
the school recently gained the attention
of the smithsonian we finally got our
foot in there yeah that's why we've
worked so hard
to get to this point
and we want to continue
no matter what it takes
it is a legacy
a history that needs to be told a group
of individuals
that were educated here
that went on to
be
positive people in society
absolutely embodying a lesson they
learned more than 50 years ago from
their role model never give up
for cbs saturday morning deborah
alfarone powhatan virginia
i had no idea never heard of saying a
lot of people did and i love that line
from enslavement to empowerment right oh
absolutely
they are their ancestors wildest dreams
amazing